normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have the story is China's mystery
pneumonia sweeping Europe Netherlands
sees alarming Surge and similar illness
among children as terrifying video shows
Hazmat clad workers in China
disinfecting schools I keep seeing
people say don't fall for it as we're
getting more and more data of a strange
respiratory illness well now they're
gonna they're goingon to make sure that
children are a vector of it because last
time children were not a vector yeah can
you overlay poll Trump's poll num over
this actually you know I think I think
we actually can do we have no we don't
have right here oh wait wait hold on
Trump's poll lead expands with Biden
losing black and his stanic support well
you get the general idea but is it the
flu I mean they're calling it a
pneumonia yeah but it's also winter and
people get sick more in Winter I don't
know look I'm not a doctor talk to your
doctor I'm just saying surprise surprise
as we're entering an election year all
of a sudden we're getting this news
hopefully it goes nowhere but remain
Vigilant watch out for these attempts to
shock and scare you and create Panic so
that you vote for their their their
choice of
candidate yeah I think we have to
remember that it's also a lot of uh
anti-id stuff I heard somebody saying
that some of the video was lifted from
the from Co in the past so some of the
videos yeah some of the videos like
cleaning and disinfecting and stuff like
that was Liv from the past because not a
lot of media comes out of China unless
it comes out of the China Post just like
when CBS posted video of a
from New York but it
was numerous agencies did that for
months they kept the same thing over and
over again same man same thing that's
okay so so here's look I often when I'm
reading the news I can imagine possible
scenarios when it comes to polling like
you know Moody will come out and say the
economy is doing so poorly Biden's going
to lose by this margin and I'm imagining
what happens I cannot visualize what
happens with Joe Biden oh no I mean he
can't he can't be the candidate they've
got to get rid of him but what do they
do do they do they act like he's going
to be the nominee and then abruptly at
the convention just announce Gavin
Newsome well also we have right now the
the likely nominee from both parties is
be are beyond the average life
expectancy of an American man I know I
know it's it's just an honest
observation that you cannot know what's
going to happen I mean it's always true
that you can't know what but especially
now you can't know what's going to
happen in this election okay to be fair
to be fair Trump is almost at the life
expectancy which is I believe 79 yeah
and Biden is it's dropping though the
life expectancy for American men y i I'm
not saying that means a whole lot when
he's a year and a half away from the
average expectancy but I can't picture
Biden getting oh wait no I'm sorry I'm
sorry uh no Jeremy was correct it went
it went down it so the latest it's like
73 I think so the last time we checked
it was actually 70 78 79 and uh the
latest numbers are now 77.2 eight so in
fact you are correct sir Trump is 77 I
can't imagine Biden in the white house
uh at all I still can't but I want
wonder if it's going to be him bowing
out and they're going to play like this
Valiant way of him leaving like oh it
was a noble thing to do he stepped down
we're going to get you
know something be a heart attack or do
they they play The Tragedy card which is
what a lot of people in government love
to do so it's got It's got do it a lot
it's got to be a heart attack or
something yeah I don't know or they just
prop him up and keep it going
McConnell's still there I mean he is old
yeah but he can't win no but he's still
there I mean you'd think someone be like
we got to get you you're saying Joe
Biden can't win Joe Biden no I don't
think that's true you think he can I
think he can win yeah okay let me say
this as of right now all data indicates
Biden will not win yep there's a lot of
reasons why he can win I'm just saying I
think that it has been thus far it has
been a great asset not a liability that
Joe Biden is nearly dead he defeat he
defeated Trump in 2020 by being a corpse
like that was actually that was actually
the the best recommendation that you
could make for him totally well that's
what uh was it Atlantic who wrote that
stay alive Joe Biden all we need is your
Corporal form dud that's one of my
favorite Shane Gillis jokes he says like
that's what Trump does he gets inside
people's minds but you can't get into
Joe's head's not even there man that
well so what's what's the realistic
scenario you think Biden runs in
whatever corpse-like fashion which means
not doing anything but then people vote
for him well one thing you have to know
about Democrats historically in
elections
is none of their internal rules actually
matter yeah so just as an example if
you're a Democrat and you die after an
election is ostensibly
underway they just put your they just
let people vote for you and then put
your wife in and then they put your wife
in there's nothing legal about that
there's nothing no no per the bylaws
they just do it was was that in
Pennsylvania was that in Pennsylvania
where was it uh we we did cover this
yeah there was a a politician was
running he died just before election day
they said whatever and then his wife was
appointed to fill the role familiar
something like that I think it was like
a senator or something like that how do
they just pass that how do they just say
that's okay well because because when uh
uh party rules well a a Governor's
appoint Senator if there's a vacancy so
like when when Obama got elected and
Illinois had an open seat bovich
famously said I'm not giving this away
this thing away for free or whatever the
quote was right you went to jail for it
pardoned by Trump right well oh yeah
that's right that's right wow Illinois
is one this is this is a thing that
keeps happening and but why the wife
like why would they just default to the
wife I think they were hoping widows who
succeed their husbands in Congress that
happens a lot oh yeah that's weird and
there's articles about this going back
to 2014 what this is Lady Ballers 2 but
but so I I understand this but what's
President doct J
Biden what's the scenario then I this is
why this is my point point I I I can
understand what you're saying the rules
don't matter but so what is the
realistic scenario that we witness in
2024 are we as political junkies going
to be watching like figuratively it's a
debate stage with a with an empty space
and Trump yelling at the wind ai ai
Biden yeah no but I mean in the news
we're going to have Trump Trump trump is
it just going to be nothing about the
Democrats at all yeah they could run
everything in the way he Biden ran his
campaign that's essentially how that's
was their strategy in 2020 stay Stayed
in the basement stay in the basement
stay down there his weird Studio they
manipulate the reality through corporate
press a lot of people buy into it and
that's that if if that's the case if you
if you compare the uh political uh
polling average today to 2020 it is
completely inverted and Trump is on a on
a path towards major victory I think
this time is different though because
he's shown what he does as the president
he's shown like his hand he doesn't have
like the we don't know what he's going
to be like in the we we really did we
you looked back into his political
history he knew what he was going to be
like but the average person didn't know
what Joe Biden was going to be like as
president I think he's already shown
what he's like the NBC poll that we sded
recent just a moment ago shows that if
the Democrats have any other candidate
Trump loses it's one poll don't know if
it's true but they say if it's Trump V
Biden Biden loses if it's Trump versus
any Democratic candidate Trump loses
people love Nome I I don't do they
really how they when I was in California
at the GOP debate that dude walked up
into the Reagan Library GOP debate yeah
uh the second one and he he showed up
and people fawned over him Sean Hannity
practically made out with with new in
front of me I mean they were so smitten
with each other it was disgusting and um
I I talked to a lot of uh conservative
women who find Nome Charming yeah they
know he's depraved nasty and gross but
there's something about him he's like
this poster boy for politics of days old
where he's got the hair and all this
stuff they find something Charming I
don't think they'd vote for him he like
a lizard man he well I know he is I saw
him change out of that suit yeah I feel
like he's Democrat Mitt Romney though
yeah I think he Romney is more like a
Saltine though who's ineffective has a
past of actual depravity and a liar like
a big time liar I don't see how Nome
doesn't become president the guy yeah
terrifi just think about his career path
destroy San Francisco become governor
destroy
California's president he steps into the
Wasteland of America destroy uh Middle
East and South America the Korean
Peninsula and then become Supreme
Chancellor there you go something like
that he's got the look but you what you
say Romney's a Saltine yeah I think so
like dry and UNP there's just nothing
about like what has he done that's I I
don't know about him as well as I know
Nome but he seems like he hasn't been as
effective in positive or negative ways
well we got uh was it new V de santis on
H Thursday yeah when Romney was in
Massachusetts for a while right was that
where he was yeah uh so I don't know I
don't know how people thought of him
back then and people liked him for to me
uh he looks like he's just like Obama in
many ways you know the way he talk no no
no uh Romney the way Romney talks now is
is basically he's like Obama you know
they're they're they're into war uh
they're part of the uni party and uh I'm
tired of that and Nome is the king of
all that crap they all they all look up
to Nome yeah I I can imagine the
Democratic Convention happens and they
just say we all the super delicates have
teamed up to vote for Nome your votes
don't matter he apologized for his covid
ways
that's enough for them I don't think
they' even bring that up because he
already apologized they wouldn't blow
right by it just I
mean who else they pick on the left do
you think Nome is is running 2024 you
think he's going to be the guy I mean we
all think he's secretly well no one will
run against Biden it it all comes down
to what happens with Biden but if Biden
is not running which I think to be clear
Biden is currently running to be
president so something has to change
right then yeah I think nome's probably
the go-to guy I think they flirted with
the idea of it being Buddha for a while
that's just not going to happen oh gosh
no he's terrible he's terrible and he
took all that time off he's just a waste
I mean when I was in East Palestine
after the train exploded the way he
handled that whole situation those
people were Furious I mean Furious and
that's how a lot of America felt
watching him visit I'm putting in quotes
uh East Palestine it just is atrocious
but I don't know a lot of people can
agree how terrible Nome was in
California but they still there's a lot
of people who still love him you know
yep so I could see him but they like
Jeremy's right he's not going to go
against uh but right so is Biden how's
Biden gonna be out well Biden has even
said Gavin Newsome could have my job
yeah recently well Kam nobody likes
kamla nobody liked Kamala when she was
running what was it she got like she had
3% of the vote before she dropped out of
the primary she was trash and everyone
know knows it she's also the one who is
essentially responsible in part for this
whole border thing she was supposed to
be in charge of it and her you know and
she was supposed to deal with the border
and her office was like nuh-uh no she
isn't that's nuh what border right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net